[Música]
en eeuu republicanos y demócratas
llegaron a un acuerdo sobre un control
mínimo de las armas de fuego el
presidente yo bailé dijo que esta
decisión sería la más importante en esta
materia que se apruebe en el congreso en
décadas pero para algunos el acuerdo es
insuficiente
polémica en nicaragua por un decreto
presidencial que pide al parlamento
permitir la entrada de militares naves y
aeronaves rusas al territorio mientras
el gobierno dice que se concentrarán en
combatir ilícitos sus detractores
consideran que se trata de una falsa
tenemos análisis
colombia elige presidente el próximo
domingo 19 de junio más de 39 millones
de personas decidirán entre gustavo
petro y rodolfo hernández y la
desigualdad será un tema clave en estas
elecciones les contamos cuál es la
situación del país
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en eeuu un grupo de
20 senadores republicanos y demócratas
llegaron a un acuerdo sobre un control
mínimo de las armas de fuego el
presidente joe biden señaló que esta
podría ser la legislación de control de
armas más importante que se apruebe en
el congreso en décadas pero para algunos
este acuerdo resulta insuficiente
informe de albert
importante pero insuficiente
en eeuu así es como los activistas han
descrito un nuevo acuerdo entre
demócratas y republicanos sobre el
control de armas de fuego el paquete de
medidas que requiere una mayoría para
ser aprobado por el senado incluye un
incentivo para que los estados se
retiren las armas a las personas
consideradas peligrosas un reforzamiento
de la comprobación de los antecedentes
penales y psicológicos de los
compradores de 18 a 21 años y la
financiación de diversos programas de
salud mental pero estas medidas no
incluyen el grueso de las reformas que
los demócratas han estado y yendo y
muchos activistas las tildaron de
inadecuadas por ejemplo el proyecto de
reformas no incluye la prohibición de
las armas semiautomáticas la prohibición
de los cargadores de gran capacidad la
edad mínima de 21 años para comprar
rifles tipo ar-15 y la verificación
universal de los antecedentes de los
compradores sin embargo el presidente de
eeuu se felicitó de que los avances sean
importantes
no hace todo lo que creo que es
necesario pero refleja pasos importantes
en la dirección correcta la presencia de
10 senadores republicanos entre los
firmantes del acuerdo sugiere que tiene
posibilidades reales de ser aprobado por
el senado el sábado 11 de julio miles de
estadounidenses se manifestaron para
pedir un mayor control de las armas tras
recientes tiroteos que dejaron decenas
de muertos en otras noticias de eeuu el
comité de la cámara de representantes
que investiga el asalto al capitolio del
6 de enero de 2021 realizará una nueva
audiencia este lunes y anunciaron tener
suficiente evidencia para que el
departamento de justicia considere una
acusación penal sin precedentes contra
el ex presidente de donald trump por
tratar de anular los resultados de las
elecciones de 2020 entre los citados a
testificar se encuentran el director de
campaña de trump vio este fin
[Aplausos]
en nicaragua el presidente daniel ortega
pidió a la asamblea nacional donde tiene
una mayoría absoluta que aprueben el
ingreso de tropas naves y aeronaves de
las fuerzas rusas al país el objetivo
según el gobierno es participar en
operaciones en contra de ilícitos en el
mar caribe y en el océano pacífico
nicaragüense
previamente hablamos con israel el ebit
es analista político y activista
nicaragüense en el exilio quien nos
contó su opinión sobre esta medida
definitivamente rusia y junto con él yo
diría en bloque totalitario global ven
en al de ortega un aliado estratégico en
el centro de las américas y anne ortega
no titubea en prestar el territorio y en
exponer a nuestra nación a ser un peón
en en una guerra geopolítica donde
obviamente dijeron a ciudadanía la peor
parte con tal de obtener réditos para él
y su camarilla entonces la participación
de ortega básicamente se resume a
decirle a putin te prestamos el
territorio dispongan como sea necesario
y decirle eeuu bueno que me das a cambio
para que yo no le de semejante entrada a
rusia el próximo domingo 19 de junio se
llevará a cabo la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia un
país en el que 4 de cada 10 ciudadanos
viven bajo el umbral de la pobreza y en
el que la desigualdad juega un papel
fundamental en la decisión de voto con
un empresariado que históricamente ha
apoyado a la derecha y una clase popular
que muchas veces prefiere abstenerse o
vender su sufragio casi 40 millones de
colombianos están llamados a las urnas
detalles en el siguiente reportaje
preparado por daniela blandón y benjamin
y mar
fue el epicentro del comercio de
esclavos y uno de los puertos más
importantes para los españoles durante
la conquista siglos después la joya
turística de colombia cartagena es uno
de los motores económicos y un lugar
seguro para la inversión en un país tan
rico en recursos como desigual héctor
trujillo es miembro de la élite de
antaño y fue gerente regional de la
asociación nacional de empresarios y el
poder empresarial está en manos de
empresas extranjeras estas empresas
están direccionadas tanto en su parte
económica como en su parte política
desde el centro de colombia para él en
plena campaña electoral la política para
los empresarios tradicionalmente de
derecha pasa a un segundo plano si de
dinero se trata pero grandes
conglomerados con tal de quedarse pactan
con crecer
y la clase media la que estar sufriendo
y el empresario intermedio para ser
testigos de esa creciente inversión
basta con visitar las viejas casonas de
la perla del caribe hoy convertidas en
hostales hoteles boutique y lujosos
restaurantes
ya 10 martínez pasa la mayor parte de
sus días en getsemaní
el otrora sector más pobre de la
cartagena amurallada hoy protagonista
del boom turístico en españa según ella
los recursos que van y vienen no los
llegan a beneficiar a todos la riqueza
como tal
no se ve reflejada de 100% la mayoría
de barrio las mamás se prostituya porque
no consiguen un empleo porque no hay una
capacitación porque hay veces que pronto
quieren trabajar quieren digamos que
salir adelante para unai oportunidades
su verdadera realidad como la de muchos
otros miles de cartageneros al servicio
de la industria y del turismo está en la
periferia unas 80 mil personas habitan
en este barrio en donde la pobreza y la
abstención electoral van de la mano al
área ya desconfía en que con su voto
contribuirá a que la situación algún día
cambie su tierra y opina lo contrario la
gente por la que casi la mayoría de la
gente no vota
porque los políticos no hacen nada por
este barrio entonces a veces la gente le
da miedo
según el banco mundial colombia es el
segundo país más desigual de américa
latina después de brasil como bien lo
prueba el diario vivir en 2 cartagenas
reflejo de dos colombias distintas una
con un desarrollo a todo vapor y otro
que siente que jamás saldrá de la
pobreza el tráfico ilegal de animales es
el séptimo negocio ilícito más lucrativo
en el mundo en mexico el poder económico
de los narcotraficantes ha sido
acompañado de la compra de animales
exóticos donde una cría de león puede
costar entre mil y cinco mil dólares
pero muchos de sus animales acaban en
reino animal una reserva cerca de ciudad
de mexico luís muñoz tiene más detalles
así estaba frida en 2018 cuando la
abandonaron en un parqueadero de ciudad
de méxico así está hoy regia
contoneándose en la reserva de reino
animal de donde vemos que fijase se
recuperó de la lesión que tenía al 100%
y las condiciones portátiles pues pues
nos da mucho gusto tenerlo esa manera
porque ya no ya no sufre el ejemplar ya
está bien ya la vemos con una calidad
muy muy bueno este es el nuevo hogar
para animales rescatados tras ser
adquiridos como mascotas o en posesión
de criminales está reserva cuenta con
1.100 animales que van desde jaguares
incluso hasta jirafas
en méxico se decomisan cada año entre
150 y 200 animales exóticos el tráfico
mundial de fauna salvaje aporta
ganancias de entre 7.000 y 23.000
millones de dólares es el séptimo
negocio ilícito más lucrativo por
ejemplares exóticos como tienen un costo
considerable para su manejo atención son
adquiridas por gente que tiene un alto
poder adquisitivo
desgraciadamente hemos percibido que los
últimos años esto ha sido a cargo de
grupos de delincuencia organizada y se
han estado coincidiendo con cateos a
ubicaciones donde tienen aparte de los
enervantes tienen ejemplares de esta
naturaleza una práctica que llegó hasta
el chapo guzmán uno de los principales
narcotraficantes mexicanos su mona botas
de hecho habría ayudado a encontrar su
rastro y detenerle
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]